en fait michel terrot bonjour bonjour
monsieur niveau oui bonjour spiritains
et où martiniquais
vous êtes président des républicains de
martinique vous présenter un second
mandat ou cet esprit vous avez 46 ans
est avocat vous allez conduire la liste
le saint-esprit avant tout qu'est ce qui
vous motive aujourd'hui à monsieur les
bruits vous avez oublié que sur le maire
du saint-esprit
ce qui me motive c'est poursuivre le
travail que l'équipe de cet esprit avant
tout a commencé depuis 2014 puisque nous
sommes arrivés il ya six ans et nous
avons trouvé une situation financière
assez désastreuse nous avons redressé la
barre et puis nous avons engagé une
dynamique au niveau culturel dans la
commune nous avons réhabilité aussi
plusieurs bâtiments nous avons mis les
écolos nomme nous avons fait de la ville
une ville fleurie ville qui vient
d'obtenir la troisième fleur et qui est
deuxième au concours des villes et
villages fleuris
donc ce que nous souhaitons c'est
poursuivre le travail qui était engagée
il ya six ans et puis faire du
saint-esprit une ville où il fait bon
vivre
alors qu'est-ce qui pour quoi vous
opposants disent que la ville se meurt
qu'il y à un manque de dynamisme qui
manque d'attractivité à je n'ai pas
entendu c'est vous qui avez entendu ça
mais tous ceux qui habitent ou cet
esprit et autour les attend au tour
savent que cet esprit maintenant c'est
une ville très attractive au niveau
culturel on parle tous les jours du
dynamisme de la médiathèque nouvelle qui
vient de se passer a été le théâtre de
pas mal de manifestations pour les
petits poulets grand donc fait cet
esprit est une ville de plus en plus
dynamique au niveau culturel au niveau
sportif
donc ceux qui le disent mans je les
laisse à leur propos mais ceux qui
résident dans la commune ici les
habitants du sud savent que cet esprit
est une ville de plus en plus attractif
au niveau sportif mais l'éclairage du
stade
enfin on dit que l'église que leycuras
du stade n'ai pas ri que n'est pas je
sais où vous prenez vos informations
monsieur niveau équipe ii
notez d'éclairage et qui étaient
installés en 2010 était extrêmement
performant ça me permet de de dire que
nous avons effectivement réalisé une
engagement qui avait été pris en 2014 de
donner au saint-esprit un éclairage de
compétition donc non seulement l'équipe
du stade est très contente et très fière
d'utiliser ce stade mais l'équipe
féminine également et puis les équipes
des villes hôtes où viennent
régulièrement jouer sur notre terrain de
foot c'est un éclairage performant qui
qui a fait tout tout la preuve de son
efficacité on vous reproche de ne pas
être proche d'eux justement de la
population et de ne pas associer les
samaritains les spiritains parlons les
spirit à la gestion communale de moi
ceux qui disent ah je leur donne rendez
vous le 15 mars et puis nous verrons ces
disparités qui vont décider le juge
arbitre c'est le peuple
nous attendons le la réponse de la
population le 15 mars
en parlant de gestion
où en est on de la caisse des écoles y
avait un déficit soit environ 800 mille
euros ce déficit qui ai connu beaucoup
de caisses des écoles de la martinique
sont en difficulté on va pas rappeler
toutes les difficultés qui ont eu lieu
avec la suppression des contrats aidés
la caisse des écoles effectivement dû
cet esprit connaît quelques difficultés
mais qui vont être résolus d'ici quatre
à cinq ans c'est l'objectif que nous
nous sommes donnée puis la chambre
régionale des comptes est parfaitement
conscient de ces difficultés et nous a
indiqué que les mesures que nous avons
prises sont de nature à régler le
problème dans le temps que je vous ai
indiqué alors quelles sont les priorités
là pour vous pour la commune et bien
donc continuer d' assainir les finances
et faire en sorte que cet esprit soit la
capitale culturelle du sud c'était notre
objectif faire en sorte aussi que nous
soyons une référence en matière
environnementale nous avons donc trois
fleurs au niveau du fleurissement nous
avons trois feuilles également c'est à
dire que la ville de cet esprit
n'utilise aucun pesticide pour le
fauchage mécanisée pour l'utilisation de
on n'utilise pas de pesticides savez que
nous sommes respectueux de
l'environnement donc nous souhaitons
faire du saint-esprit une référence en
matière environnementale alors lien
rapport parlementaire sur les communes
d'outre-mer qui préconise une meilleure
maîtrise des dépenses de personnel et la
mise en place de contrats
d'accompagnement de 30 millions d'euros
pour les communes en grande difficulté
votre avis sur ce rapport il ya aussi 46
mesurant tout ça va dans le bon sens
cinq minute changeait pas l'auteur de de
m'appesantir sur ce rapport qui
forcément va utiliser en très grande
difficulté ce n'est pas notre cas donc
nous nous occupons de notre personnel
nous formons régulièrement le personnel
que ce soit aux formations qui
correspondent à leurs missions
respectives mais aussi nous les formant
aux gestes de premiers secours et nous
avons aussi une très bonne entente avec
les syndicats avec qui nous collaborons
en parfaite harmonie
l'important c'est qu'il y ait très bons
rapports entre les élus et les
administratifs et cela cas
fête des jeunes tirent eux je vous
remercie et je profite quand même de
votre entraîne pour souhaiter à tous les
spirit et à tous les martiniquais une
bonne et heureuse année 2020